The world of Dune is known for its scale
and its futuristic yet
strangely familiar technology,
But its most recognizable feature
is probably its brutal environment.
According to research, humans can survive for only about 10 minutes
at a temperature of 121 degrees Celsius.
If they're in a dry environment
and 60 degrees Celsius
if they're in a humid environment.
But the people of the planet
Arrakis have figured out a way to survive
in a climate that's on average
between 45 degrees Celsius in the lowlands
and 70 degrees Celsius in the waistlines
And it's not just the heat.
They have to deal with the wind,
which blows up to 750 kilometers an hour.
The sandstorms
and a complete lack of water.
and not only survive,
they've built cities and wealth
and also some
really strange local customs.
And the world is
full of these details,
both high-tech and low-tech, that exhibit
how they've managed to survive
in these brutal, inhospitable conditions.
And although it's set in the year
10,000, this fictional world
might actually give us some insights
into our own futures as well.
A portion of this video is sponsored
by Wayfair,
Frank Herbert
wrote Dune in 1965
after his visit to the Oregon Dunes.
This was a time when he was kind
of struggling with his career.
He went to Florence, Oregon, to write
a magazine article about these sandstorms.
Apparently, winds were blowing
in from the Pacific Ocean
and destabilizing the sand,
and it was threatening the communities
along the coast.
But instead of writing the article,
he ended up writing
a bestselling masterpiece.
Oh, and he was
really into magic mushrooms.
No big deal.
Arrakis, as you might have
guessed, was written to be allegorical
to the petrol-rich countries
like the ones in the Middle East.
And if you don't know the story,
the reason why they stay living in this
inhospitable planet is because it's
the only place in the universe
they can produce Spice,
also known as Mélange.
Spice is a fictional substance
that can extend life.
It can give you enhanced abilities.
And you can only do space travel
If you're high on spice
And therefore, it's the most valuable
substance in the universe.
as a byproduct of a sandworms lifecycle,
which is intertwined
with the desert ecology of the planet.
And so as the producer
of the most valuable substance
in the universe,
It makes Arrakis the only source of spice,
the wealthiest and most strategically
important location in the universe.
There have been efforts
to terraform the planet to be
a little bit more livable,
but changing the atmosphere
will essentially deprive
the planet of its most valuable resource.
So all of these efforts
have been stalled So,
yes, it's a story about sandworms
and space travel, but it's also about
geopolitical conflicts
around the exploitation
of natural resources
and the effects of a changing climate.
Arrakis sits on a sheet of
bedrock nestled within a mountain
bore on the north pole of the planet.
And these nice people actually made
a climate simulation of the planet
Arrakis to see how accurate
the descriptions in the book were.
In the book,
it describes a planet with unforgiving sun
and wasteland of sand and rock.
But as you move closer to the polar
regions toward the cities of Arrakeen,
it starts to change into something
that might be a little bit more livable.
But actually, in their simulation,
they found the opposite.
The overall climate of the planet
is actually relatively mild
and the warmest months in the tropics
hit around 45 degrees Celsius.
And the coldest dropped
just below 15 degrees Celsius.
But when you get into the polar regions,
that's when you get the extreme
temperatures.
Summers can get as hot as 70 degrees
Celsius and as low
as -75 degrees
in the winters But I digress,
There's not a
whole lot of information
on how the city is built or laid out.
But what we do know is that the city of
or Arrakeen is nestled within a mountain wall
which gives them protection from the sun
and the wind and the sandworms.
They've also built in a shield wall
on the side that doesn't have mountains.
So in a way, it's a walled city.
the city looks pretty
deserted in the movie, but the book does
describe it as a bustling city
with millions of people.
So you can maybe assume
that people come out only at night
or the entire city
is partially underground.
There's instances of cities like this
here, too, that are built into the earth
There's several advantages to this.
First, and most obvious
as protection from the heat.
But the second one is passive cooling.
If you look at termite mounds,
they look solid from the outside.
But from the inside, it's actually
really open, covered with tiny holes.
And the temperature difference
between above and below ground,
thanks to convection, creates
this steady flow of air
throughout the structure.
The focal point of the city
is the Grand Palace, which is the
residence of the ruling family.
Apparently, in the future,
under Paul's rule,
the palace gets significantly expanded
and renovated, becoming the largest
built structure known to mankind.
But today, we're just going to be talking
about the first maybe.
The building is shaped like a ziggurat,
which is also how they designed
the headquarters
of the Tyrell Corporation and Bladerunner,
because there's something about the form
and immense scale of these buildings
that illustrate power and dominance.
But in this case, the form
probably also helps
to deflect the wind
while mimicking the surrounding mountains.
It's made up of super thick, thermally
dense
material like stone or concrete
to provide protection from the heat.
there's also a lot of influence
from brutalism,
especially Brazilian brutalism,
with all these lines and angles.
The angles and heavy materials
seem to provide some hearty shelter
from the wind, and the whole thing
actually feels very defensive.
And when you go inside,
it really feels like a bunker.
It's really dark
and there's very few openings.
The openings are closer to a light
wall than windows.
They're very deep.
You don't get any views.
And it's just this diffuse,
indirect light.
They also use mesh
rabbis looks like for spaces
that have a religious purpose.
And when you compare it to Caladan
Paul's home planet, which is actually
really pleasant and habitable.
First of all, you'll notice
these big round windows and lots of light.
There's also a much richer
material palette latticed windows,
stone walls, Persian rugs,
wood floors and ceilings on furniture.
Because Caledon has water and vegetation.
Apparently,
Caledon was modeled after coastal Canada
and connotes a civilization
quietly sliding into obsolescence
idea of something that is ending like
a tradition that's going to fade away.
I just love how the rest of the world
thinks about Canada
anyways, compared to their palace
and Caladan, the Palace and Arrakis
has a very monotonous material palette,
just stone or concrete.
But it looks layered
and it looks like it's been built
over a long period of time.
and when you think future civilization,
you'll probably think of
something like this.
But here it feels ancient.
You can get a tectonic understanding
and kind of see how it's been built.
You can see the structural
framing with posts and beams.
Here it looks like a mixture of materials.
Over here it looks like sandstone or
limestone, probably mined from the hills.
And here it looks
like a board formed concrete.
You can see something
like raked concrete here
And maybe
concrete seems like the obvious choice
because, well, they have lots of sand,
but wind eroded desert sand
is practically useless for construction.
The sand we use for concrete
is this coarse,
chunky aggregate
that helps bind and strengthen concrete.
But maybe
in the future, they have figured out a way
to make concrete out of desert sand.
fact, this is something
we're already working on here on Earth
because construction
great sand is being depleted very quickly.
Did you know that sand
is the most consumed resource after water?
and big surprise were excavating it
faster than it can renew itself,
Which is why companies like Finite
have been looking into composites
using desert sand.
Apparently this new desert
sand mixes biodegradable
and it can cut the carbon
footprint in half.
So once they fine-tune this product,
I think it'll be a game changer
because sand isn't just used for building,
it's also used for glass
and computer chips.
And desert sand is pretty abundant.
But the other major
ingredient in concrete is water,
which Arrakis does not have.
So I think the most plausible answer
is that a lot of these building parts
were made on another planet
and then shipped to Arrakis.
A quick
message from today's sponsor, Wayfair.
You guys probably know Wafer as a place
where you can get chic, affordable home
products, but you might not know
about their awesome YouTube channel.
They have this cool new series
called Iconic Objects,
where they dive deep into the history
of some of the most ubiquitous yet
peculiar home decor items.
I love the series, first of all,
because I adore the host Caroline Winkler,
and also because you start to realize the
weirdest objects have a cult following.
It goes beyond just history
and gets into the raw
of why we're attracted to certain objects.
I would highly recommend their new episode
on the Bialetti Moka Pot,
a timeless coffee maker They continues
to outshine its modern counterparts.
The show was well-made,
well-researched and it's fun to watch.
So yeah, go
and subscribe to their channel.
It's full of really great content.
I'll include the link in the description.
As we move away from our
skin, we start to see how the locals live
in the desert.
The Fremen have lived in the desert
for generations and generations.
So they've adapted to living
in this harsh environment
and they've become kind of experts
in desert survival.
And it's really interesting to see
how differently they approach building.
The first from instructor we see as their
ecological testing station,
which has a very different tectonic
language than the Palace in Arrakeen.
Instead of large blocks of stone,
you see layers.
It looks like it could be rammed Earth,
which is a pretty ancient
construction technique, very popular
in drier and hotter parts of the world
where you grab damp soil
made from aggregates,
sand,
silt, clay and gravel into a formwork.
But when you look
at the shape of the walls
and how it becomes
the ceiling, it's not likely rammed Earth
because rammed Earth is mostly
just strong in compression.
Over here, it looks like it could be 3D
printed concrete, but again, with concrete
you need water actually in the back
story of the Dune universe.
It is hinted that Iraq is was originally
a pretty lush planet
and that the sandworms somehow affected
the atmosphere and turn it into a desert.
So one possibility
is that these structures were built back
then, but the outside tells
a whole different story.
It looks like the entire building
is carved out of the hill,
Petra
is an entire
city that was carved into the mountains.
And in fact,
parts of the movie were filmed in Jordan.
Petra was built in the fourth century B.C.
by this fascinating Arab Bedouin
tribe called the Nabateans
They were once nomads,
but they became very wealthy
by trading spice
and they settled in Petra.
They use this mountain terrain
as a natural barrier against enemies
and the harsh climate, so much
so that they started carving buildings
directly into the cliffs.
apparently the city was built to align
with the sun.
And on days like the winter solstice,
the sun would align with
some of the most important buildings.
so when you look closely at the structures
in the movie, you can see
the layers similar to what you observe
in the buildings in the hills of Petra.
and there's instances
in this ecological testing station
where you can see
how the building interplays with the sun.
I know that the Fremen were inspired
by the Bedouin tribe,
but I think the Nabateans
in particular, have a lot of similarities.
I think one of the most amazing things
about the Fremen
is their technology
to conserve water like this.
Still tonight, although they're not really
discussed in the movie,
they use a very similar principle
as the stillsuits
These tents are designed to provide
shelter in the harsh desert environment,
and they can capture and reclaim moisture
that you exhale or perspire.
It's also lightweight
and compact and in camouflage,
just perfectly into the desert.
It also keeps the interior environment
cool and humid and it's completely sealed.
So moisture does not escape.
although it doesn't explicitly sabers,
the concepts used and stole
suits and soul tents is similar
to the function of many desert animals.
For example, the Australian thorny
Devil lizard is known to channel rainwater
and do from its skin directly into its
mouth through its grooves,
They call this mouse mouth deep,
which directly translates into instructor
or teacher.
they're perfectly adapted to the desert.
So they've become a symbol of resilience
and adaptability.
In fact, the Fremen have modeled
their wind traps after these mice
and how they collect water vapor
in their large ear flaps.
When traps capture the wind and funnel it
into this underground chamber
where the moisture in the air condenses
due to cooler temperatures.
And then it's collected in this catch
basin for storage.
Wooden
traps are not entirely fictional and
could be a cross between these two devices
atmospheric water generators
extract water from humid ambient air.
They use cooling coils
to condense moisture from the air similar
to how air conditioner works.
they do require a power source and are
mostly effective in humid environments.
They're also a lot smaller
than these wind traps.
These are wind catchers or partials.
it's a pretty ancient method
of passively
cooling buildings in hot and arid regions.
They essentially capture wind
and direct it into buildings
to provide natural ventilation
and passive cooling.
The tower is designed to catch the wind
and funnel it downward
and the pressure differential pushes
hot air out of the building.
Sometimes they're paired
with an underground channel transporting
water called canards, which cooled the air
before it circulates the building.
There's even modern buildings.
Let's use wind captures
with some really great results.
and it's allowed them to avoid mechanical
AC units and also
reduce their emissions.
the most interesting part of Dune for me
is this huge
contrast between the local Fremen
and the ruling families.
Whether it's house Harkonnen
or house of Atredis.
And I think it actually offers
some really valuable insights.
The newcomers,
even though they're technically
the most powerful and resourceful family
they struggle to adapt to Arrakis,
has harsh conditions, and they rely mostly
on imported resources.
the fremen, on the other hand,
they've been able to develop solutions
that are locally adapted approaches
that are specifically designed
for this climate.
Instead of seeking universally applicable
high tech solutions,
maybe we need to be looking more
for nuanced locally adapted approaches.
And sometimes the solutions
come from observing
seemingly insignificant moments
that happen right under our noses.
Anyways, let me know
what you guys think in the comments below.
and if you want to keep up to date
with what we're doing,
I have a newsletter and a Discord server.
I'll leave the link in the description
and with that I'll see
you guys in the next video.